have you heard of bob prophet ed
siratellini
no he's a prophet he heals people mike
i'm not going to give you any background
i'm just going to play this video
i want you to pick what does he spell
prophet the p-r-o-p-h-e-t
oh okay so he's just come back all right
so check it out here you go
this little intro to his video
deliverance
that's him
manifestations of evil spirits
these people are going to hell right oh
the i think they go to the
darkest depths of hell that's the stuff
okay this
cause they should go to hell yeah here
you go
[Music]
but it gets better look at them look at
that demo look look oral sex
oral sex demons you see oral sex look
oral sex look look look
oh it's an oral sex demon you
you are a sex use our sex let that sperm
of that man out
out of yours
not on my floors let's go let's go let's
go let's go
two sundays are back then a demon came
with
wait i'm i'm curious now did she like
just suck a dick because
no the digestive system works very
quickly
she didn't just it's a demon dick she
explains it you'll see and i mean once
it's in the stun you're not getting
whatever two sundays are back then
a demon came with his penis and put it
in my mouth
it's pretty clear
it's pretty clear and that the demon's
name was darnell
and he lives up the block
and and then he tried he came again and
he slept with me last week and i i told
the pastor that i need deliverance again
and since then my private party's been
itching
the demon got her private part itching
yes
okay who are you who are you
who are you speak who are you
who are you she's she's screaming she's
screaming
here's my thing right she's now
screaming here's my thing right so we
so we uh we gave
these uh uh noble
christianity and uh they
they kind of started this little circus
approach to it
and then we kind of took it back from
them and do the same thing
because they started the faith healing
oh yeah the spirits and the [ __ ] demons
and all that [ __ ]
that's like nigerian christians do that
[ __ ] [ __ ] demon
look at that dude look at that look at
that church is located in yonkers new
york by the way that's that's where
they're located like yonkers new york
yeah look at that looking at them
who are you who are you
oh know what he's doing
speak out who are you who are you
so what she did was she couldn't improv
a name so she fake passed out that's
what you saw
there it's good thing just pale she
couldn't improv a name so she just
passed that yeah
jesus you demon gonna help you yeah
did he make a noise
you know what this looks like honestly
awesome fun
it looks like this looks like a vic
burger video
it does but it's not vic berger hasn't
touched this video
no this is from they did this they
seriously posted this
but it feels like a vic bur it feels
like vic berger [ __ ] with this video
yes but he did not
come up from the private part ah
you ain't her private part they want in
a private party
it's not a demon that's probably some
sort of sti
it's a spring holy water he's spraying
holy water on it
um the holy water okay but let's be fair
right you're spraying it on our dress
so it's not is it going to get through
to the holy water is pretty strong i
mean jesus blessed it still water though
but it's holy water so what does that
change it's it's uh
viscosity i believe so clothing maybe it
does
who are you to question god you're right
come out from the private come on
just look
what is your name russ man
rosamund daniel rajaman daniel
what happened to you today so you prayed
for you delivered me today and then when
i went to the bathroom i think 15
minutes later
some white stuff came out with the blood
after you sprayed
oh come on somebody after i spray oh
that's cause he's using ammonia i like
that they took
fake heel healing uh uh preaching
to a new gross level oh yeah this is
yeah this is even even more but
when you thought you couldn't be more
blasphemous in the eyes of god
uh all of dane says [ __ ] and spazz are
my favorite degenerates 20 bucks thank
you olive
with the water after i spray something
came out white
put your hands together hallelujah may
your healing and deliverance be
permanent and jesus then come on and
keep the
let me ask you something pastor ed are
you gonna [ __ ] her without a condom
probably good point him probably
mike they have a phone number they're in
new york do you want to call them
i think we should call them right sure
all right let's call them
here we go
thank you for calling essecinelli
ministries for the prayer line
please press one for the bookstore
please press two
for the administration office please
press three
classes
and then we could always try three
not good service it's terrible this is
not great service
i thought it'd be at least be a
voicemail line or something no yeah no
no it's
yeah not even a voicemail prayer line's
down guys i guess uh
god's just not interesting i'm gonna try
one more time and i'm gonna try
option option three which is their
administrations
thank you for calling shinelli
ministries for the prayer line
trying three now
hi you have reached the administration
office please leave your name and number
and i will get back to you as soon as i
can have a blessed day
is not available to take your call
please leave a message
after the tone press the pound key to
end recording
[Music]
uh hi good afternoon my name is ken
fresno i'm actually calling um i heard
that you folks are the premier [ __ ]
demon
experts and uh we've got a real serious
[ __ ] demon situation going on about it
around here we really need prayer uh we
really need
uh god to move in in a big way and very
quickly
uh if you could get back to me my number
is four zero seven six
three zero nine six three six and again
i mean this is a serious [ __ ] demon type
situation it's [ __ ] me right
please stop [ __ ] me stop please in
the name of jesus stop it
so i'm i'm look i'm only as good
equipped for this
as uh as as any normal layman and i
really need your help
i really need your help the [ __ ] demons
are they're everywhere
it's weird
thank you to send your message press
three
or hang up to delete your message has
been sent
to access the voice portal alright good
so i think we i think you know we got
the message across
um hopefully they'll be contacting you
soon mikey it will be amazing i did
actually give them our hotline number so
it'll be great if they if they were to
curse if
they were to contact us that would be
fantastic